c'est à présent l'heure de votre
rendez-vous à cette heure-ci dans Paris
direct on va plus loin
[Musique]
pour m'accompagner en plateau ce soir
Patricia allemania bonsoir vous êtes
grand reporter spécialiste des questions
internationales à ma gauche Bruno Daru
chroniqueur international ici à France
24 Merci à VOUS Laurent d'être la
bonsoir Bruno c'est donc aujourd'hui que
le Liban et Israël on en a parlé ont
signé l'accord délimitant leurs
frontières maritime avant d'évoquer
l'aspect politique ou pas ça dépend de
quelqu’un on se trouve dans quel camp on
se trouve un mot sur l'aspect pécunier
avec vous Bruno est-ce qu'on peut parler
d'un accord gagnant gagnant sur le plan
économique ou pas du tout
c'est un peu tout pour le dire d'abord
il va falloir voir comment l'accord
s'applique mais facile s'applique c'est
quand même a priori oui un accord
gagnant-gagnant pour les deux parties
pour Israël parce que ça va lui
permettre de réduire le coût de son
énergie d'une part et d'autre part
d'augmenter ses livraisons de gaz
notamment à l'Europe qui en a fort
besoin dans le contexte guerre
ukrainienne et pour le Liban ça va lui
permettre de
tirer des recettes aussi de de ce gaz ce
qui pourrait lui permettre d'améliorer
un peu sa situation économique qui comme
on le sait et littéralement
catastrophique depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant donc a priori un accord
gagnant-gagnant alors côté libanais ce
qu'il faut savoir quand même c'est que
c'est donc un champ pétrolifère qui
s'appelle Cana qui va être opéré a
priori par Total énergie
mais qui est en partie en eau
israélienne donc tout à l'heure voilà et
donc il y aura une partie de ces
recettes qui ira Israël il faudra voir
aussi si ce système là peut fonctionner
correctement votre sentiment Patricia
sur ce point c'est le système peut
fonctionner correctement je crois que là
on est très avancé parce que on s'avance
beaucoup parce que le champ petrolifère
le fameux champ de Cana il faut déjà
voir s'il y a beaucoup de choses dessous
et ça on le sait pas encore vraiment on
sait qu'il y a un potentiel on sait
qu'il est très profond mais on est on en
est que là alors que Israéliens ne font
pas ils ont commencé déjà
la plateforme installée par technique ou
une société on va faire un petit coucou
aussi et bien
la station de pompage flottante installé
en juin un peu comment ça bosser tout de
suite alors un accord signé entre deux
pays officiellement toujours en guerre
ça n'arrive pas tous les jours mais
chaque ans vous allez le voir
l'interprète bien différemment cet
accordé
il s'agit d'une réussite politique ce
n'est pas tous les jours qu'un état et
demi reconnaît l'État d'Israël dans un
accord écrit devant la communauté
internationale ni que les États-Unis et
la France nous soutiennent et
fournissent des garanties sécuritaires
et économiques pour cet accord
et voilà ce qu'on dit le président Liban
et Michel laüne la démarcation de la
frontière maritime méridionale est un
travail technique qui n'a aucune
implication politique est-ce que c'est
de fait la reconnaissance de l'État
d'Israël par le Liban aujourd'hui Bruno
bah écoutez après chacun est dans sa
posture sémantique rhétorique politique
bon comme les deux états de toute façon
effectivement sont techniquement et
officiellement en état de guerre
ils peuvent continuer à dire à dire ça
pour entretenir un peu
j'ai envie de vous dire un peu les deux
parce que de fait cet accord n'est pas
une reconnaissance officielle de l'État
d'Israël par le Liban mais des facto il
y a quand même une forme de
reconnaissance à partir du moment où
deux états même s'ils le font dans deux
pièces séparées
le Liban il a pas signé avec un fantôme
il a signé avec l'État israélien et
vice-versa donc c'est quand même on va
dire peut-être un début de normalisation
de d'autres après côté libanais pour le
moment il est impossible au président
Aoun dans le parti est très lié au
Hezbollah lequel on le sait est très lié
à l'Iran donc il lui est impossible de
de dire que Israël n'est n'est plus un
ennemi parce que là ça va contre la doxa
iranienne totalement donc ça c'est
impossible et côté israélien
à chaque fois que on peut dire que un
état surtout arabe ennemi reconnaît
l'existence il y a toujours cette
histoire d'existence à reconnaître pour
Israël bah évidemment c'est assez
logique le Premier ministre hier à
l'appui de s'engouffre là dedans
d'autant plus qu'on est quand même à 5
jours d'élection générale anticipée qui
vont l'opposer à son éternel rival
Benyamine netanyou lequel était vent
debout contre cet accord parce que lui
estimé que ça faisait partie d'une forme
de reconnaissance
excessive voilà il était même il avait
même dit que s'il était élu il
reviendrait sur l'accord et cetera bon
là aujourd'hui il est un peu plus il
parle un peu moins l'autre annonce à
retenir de la journée Patricia c'est
celle donc de Hassan Nasrallah le chef
du Hezbollah qui annonce la fin des
exercices militaires exceptionnels ça
change quoi enfin je voudrais avant de
passer tout de suite un astrela je
voudrais un peu compléter ou revenir ou
un peu développé
cet accord tout dépend si on croit que
l'économie fait la paix vous savez
l'idée que l'Europe avec
en aisant avec la Russie des échanges
etc avec la Chine etc on a les créer un
monde où tout le monde allait s'entendre
grâce aux accords économiques grâce aux
échanges économiques si on croit ça on
se dit c'est un bon accord parce que
finalement ils vont converser si on est
plus sceptique si on se dit que Ben
regardez ce qui se passe avec l'Ukraine
regardez ce qui se passe avec la Russie
regardez ce qui se passe avec la Chine
là on se dit que les intérêts
géostratégiques de l'Iran et donc du
Hezbollah d'un côté et tout dépendra qui
deviendra le chef le premier Premier
ministre israélien dans cinq jours et
bien tout ce bel accord finalement pour
être presque nettement donc tout dépend
de la foi que vous avez en les valeurs
économiques en quelque sorte là
aujourd'hui parle d'une grande victoire
pour le Liban aujourd'hui alors là aussi
c'est des postures
ils bandes en astral
s'il ne sait pas opposé
ça prouve que aucun des deux n'y Israël
ni donc l'Iran n'a envie d'une
détérioration de la situation à la
frontière l'Iran a beaucoup d'autres
choses à s'occuper et Israël a aussi
beaucoup de problèmes internes donc pour
les deux états c'est pas le moment et
donc ça sera là et bien fait la posture
c'est une grande victoire pour tout le
monde c'est une grande victoire
cet après-midi parce que Nassera là a
dit nous nous cessons notre mobilisation
exceptionnelle mais en fait là aussi
c'était de la posture c'est-à-dire qu'il
avait dit il avait dit des drones sur
aussi les les plateformes enfin ils ont
fait des trucs
à Israël puisque effectivement le chant
pétrolifère est déjà prêt à être
exploité côté israélien il avait dit si
vous commencez à l'exploiter avant
l'accord nous intervenons etc il avait
passé donc il avait massé un peu plus de
troupes simplement faut pas rêver là il
a à l'arrière il enlève l'excès si j'ose
dire et on revient à la situation
militaire quand même d'avant qui n'est
pas
Israël n'y a pas intérêt à la à
l'intérêt à ce que dans sa zone Nord ce
soit ce soit calme parce qu'elle a
d'autres chats fouetter sa situation
politique intérieure qui reste donc très
compliqué plus la situation qui se
détériore depuis quelques semaines en ce
genre de données la situation économique
aussi en Israël qui n'est pas bonne
c'est-à-dire que les deux pays le Liban
c'est la banqueroute Israël c'est pas
formidable sur le plan économique et
Israël a tout intérêt à ce que le le
Liban commence à avoir une petite
lumière de sortie sur un plat économique
parce que un pays qui à ce point exemple
c'est très mauvais pour la stabilité
d'une région c'est d'ailleurs peut-être
pour ça que les choses se sont
accélérées au vu de la crise économique
au Liban ou en Israël ou pas alors là je
dirais que si vous voulez il y avait la
il y avait deux problèmes il y avait
effectivement les élections en Israël
qui ont été certainement poussées il y
avait aussi le fait que à une bientôt
n'est plus président donc un grand
inconnu mais il y avait derrière quand
même une forte pression américaine et
les Français se sont mis dans le jeu au
dernier moment pour pousser à une
finalement accepter ce qu'il n'avait pas
très envie d'accepter donc si vous
voulez je crois que c'était un concours
de circonstance mais je crois que sans
le fort push américain et français de
dernière minute et bien on en sera
peut-être pas arrivé là et en politique
intérieure ça peut servir hier lapide
dans 5 jours le premier novembre ah bah
lui évidemment il a c'est assez logique
il essaie de d'instrumentaliser ça de
manière politique en disant regardez
avec mon gouvernement bah il y a rabais
qui reconnaît Israël donc je fais du mon
travail et face surtout un Benyamin
Netanyahu qui est déjà sur une posture
très nationaliste et qui en plus là
c'est c'est Ali avec des parties ultra
orthodoxes et d'extrême droite
qui lui est voilà est très nationaliste
et dit non non mais cet accord c'est un
scandale ça va pas etc en terme de
campagne écoutez on verra bien on verra
bien dans 5 jours enfin après ces
élections il faut rappeler que ce sont
les 5e en trois ans
déjà on va regarder le taux de
participation parce que les Israéliens
sont quand même très fatigués de cette
instabilité qui n'en finit pas quand
même on va passer au second thème qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui la guerre en
Ukraine Vladimir Poutine a pris la
parole aujourd'hui l'occasion de
critiquer sans surprise une nouvelle
fois l'Occident on écoute tout d'abord
le président russe
pas les
occidentales la Russie défense
simplement son droit d'exister et de se
développer librement nous n'avons pas
non plus l'intention de devenir une
sorte de nouvel empire globale la Russie
ne propose pas de remplacer
l'unipolarité par la bipolarité la
tripolarité la domination de l'Ouest par
celle de l'Est du Nord ou du Sud cela
déboucherait inévitablement sur une
impasse
Vladimir Poutine qui a également déclaré
que le monde entrer dans sa période la
plus dangereuse depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale ça veut dire quoi Patricia le
message c'est que la Russie est toujours
aussi déterminée alors je pense que la
Russie est toujours déterminée que
Vladimir Poutine n'est toujours
déterminé et quant à la période la plus
dangereuse depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale bah oui un peu quand même il a
pas tort sur ce point là j'ai envie de
dire c'est peut-être l'unique point sur
ce point-là il a pas tort mais ce qui
est intéressant dans ce qui se passe
actuellement je trouve qu'on assiste un
changement de stratégie stratégie
militaire on s'est mis à taper toutes
les installations
tal et stratégie militaire stratégie de
communication Vladimir Poutine tous les
jours il fait à chaud avec les soldats
avec on le disait malade le voile en
pleine forme il parle il s'exprime etc
et aussi stratégie pour rompre
l'isolement parce qu'il a 13 qu'il a
très bien senti au dernier sommet avec
les pays de lasagne c'est qu'il était un
peu enfin voilà les Chinois l'ont salué
tranquillement les autres ont pris un
peu de distance même les Indiens donc là
on a le G20 qui arrive et pour le G20 il
a besoin de se rallier de montrer qu'il
est populaire et donc en disant oui
c'est méchants occidentaux c'est
colonisateurs ces racistes etc il plaît
un certain public en Afrique même en
Inde et en Amérique latine donc il veut
une nouvelle stratégie tout azimut
gagner des points sur le plan
international avec ça je sais pas si ça
marche pour l'instant 50 pays qui ont
pas voté
donc ça marche donc il a son petit
ces soutiens j'ai envie de dire
stratégie de communication et stratégie
militaire beaucoup de changements des
opérations de communication qui
traduisent quoi dans le fond une
certaine faiblesse sur le terrain
également
oui en tout cas il y a eu il y a eu de
toute façon des contrefortives
ukrainiennes qui qui ont rencontré un
certain succès même si la messe n'est
pas dites parce que les Russes aussi ont
quand même mobilisé les renforce en
train d'arrivée donc faut quand même
rester
un peu emballé il y a deux trois
semaines on y est ça y est l'armée russe
c'est fini bon on verra mais franchement
c'est c'est un peu trop tôt en tout cas
il y a eu effectivement moi je suis
d'accord avec Patricia
une évolution c'est-à-dire que l'élément
de guerre de civilisation il a toujours
été là pour Vladimir Poutine ça fait
très longtemps qu'il pense ça il l'a dit
il l'a écrit mais au moment de
l'intervention en Ukraine c'était
d'abord les objectifs affichés en tout
cas officiellement souvenait c'était des
militarisés des nazifiés etc donc
c'était très sur l'Ukraine quand même on
récupère un peu la ruse de Kiev la fin
la Grande Russie etc là l'élément de de
en fait qui fondait tout ça c'était
effectivement l'élément civilisationnel
c'est-à-dire contre cet Occident qui
cherche tout le temps à vouloir du mal à
la Russie c'est cet élément là qui est
passé au premier plan et effectivement
pour permettre l'avenir Poutine de ne
pas être isolé parce que effectivement
c'est sa grande crainte et le sommet qui
a eu lieu il y a quelques semaines au
Tadjikistan la beaucoup inquiété quand
même parce que c'était quand même et les
Chinois et les Indiens qui lui ont dit
en rose c'est pas le moment de faire la
guerre et va pas trop loin donc bon
c'est des soutiens enfin voilà et c'est
quand même deux puissances très
importantes donc il a besoin de
effectivement pour ces autres soutiens
plus un peu plus tir mon disque on va
dire de de faire ce discours et puis
effectivement il y a le G20 dans
quelques semaines c'est toujours pas si
il va aussi il va passer c'est un peu le
mystère aussi on sait que Biden a dit
voilà il est hors de question je lui
parle mais de toute façon il faut
attendre la réaction de la Chine qui est
l'acteur principal dans ce dossier qui
peut faire basculer cette crise moi je
crois que la Chine on sait déjà elle
peut pas elles peuvent pas faire plus la
Chine ne veut pas le visage du nucléaire
je crois que la grosse pression qui
était mise sur la Russie pour l'instant
c'est par la Chine sur le plan nucléaire
non c'est le c'est la ligne rouge pour
les Chinois et les chinois sont plutôt
sérieux je pense en fermer la ligne
rouge
les Chinois je crois que Vladimir
Poutine connaît la position chinoise ce
dont il a besoin c'est de montrer
justement à cet allié entre guillemets
chinois qu'il a plus de soutien qui
qu'il a qui peut ramener finalement l'un
de son côté parce que finalement est-ce
que l'Inde peut se ranger en tout cas
aider la Russie dans les prochains mois
ah bah l'Inde a besoin de la Russie sur
un plan militaire c'est toutes les armes
de l'Inde venait de la Russie il y avait
des liens très très forts entre l'un des
la Russie donc l'âne finalement et puis
l'un devant beaucoup maintenant et puis
elle récupère le pétrole pas cher il y a
des vrais liens qui se disent alors
simplement elle veut pas trop se fâcher
avec Lamia américain mais Vladimir
Poutine peut jouer il a des cartes alors
cet hiver on le sait sera un cap dans
cette guerre sans sortir la boule de
cristal Bruno quel est le scénario
auquel on peut s'attendre cet été non
mais est-ce que une avancée des trucs
différents cet hiver pardonnez-moi cet
hiver si les bien sûr les armes
occidentales continuent d'arriver en
Ukraine on peut s'attendre à une avancée
ukrainienne dans les prochains mois
toujours très difficile à dire oui très
difficile à dire d'abord il va y avoir
la période très difficile entre les
enfin l'automne
où il y a où il y a le phénomène des
boules là j'ai plus le nom en tête la
masse excusez-moi
les chars c'est difficile d'avancer donc
forcément il va y avoir une pause mais
plutôt là dans les dans les prochaines
semaines voilà voir maintenant ça débute
et puis après en hiver au contraire pour
les chars la neige et tout ça c'est
c'est pas mal pour bouger donc là ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est que
chaque camp serait arme les Russes euh
visiblement ont repris contact ou on
développait leur contact avec l'Iran
notamment avec ces drones et les
Ukrainiens continuent à être alimenté
par les quelque chose parce que le
problème qui reste quand même pour les
Ukrainiens c'est de sécuriser leur ciel
ça y est il n'y arrive pas encore donc
ils insistent auprès des occidentaux
pour qu'il leur fournissent et justement
on a pris que l'Espagne et le premier
pays à fournir des systèmes Hawk à
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui on l'a appris
aujourd'hui mais ce qu'il y a aussi qui
filtre en ce moment c'est l'aide que
pourrait apporter Israël Israël pour
apporter des systèmes de brouillage des
drones et une très forte pression des
Européens pour pousser Israël qui
a des skis depuis un certain temps déjà
non non mais c'est la poussée européenne
qui discrète dans ce mois qui se fait
parce que les Israéliens qu'est-ce qui
dit ils ont ces systèmes mais les
Israéliens le problème c'est qu'il
n'appliquent pas les sanctions ils
veulent pas se fâcher avec les Russes
parce que les Russes les aident en Syrie
quand les Israéliens ont besoin d'aller
taper les positions iraniennes
qui viennent aussi donc compliqué et on
va devoir s'arrêter là merci beaucoup
pour toutes ces explications Patricia
merci beaucoup Bruno on marque une
courte pause et Paris direct revient
dans moins de 3 minutes à tout de suite